[Musique]
ça un impact un peu psychologique parce
que tu ne t'attendais pas en fait à
rester bloqué ici tu t'attendais à
partir dans les B pas les plus brefs dél
mais dans les meilleures condition pour
voir bien commencer en fait mon année de
[Musique]
médecine
on ne contrôle pas la situation donc on
est bloqué ici et bon tant bien que mal
on essaie de positivé même si c'est
compliqué des fois mais on reste
toujours
[Musique]
positif coération scientifique
académique ça devait pas avoir des
limites quelle que soit la situation qui
qui qui prévaut c'était avec une
désolation qu'on a appris cette
suspension de de mobilité et de la
délivrance des
[Musique]
visas